name three websites youporn hey Don I'm
Kevin Hart Dwayne Johnson here and this
is animal timers for lad Bible and the
time it takes the dog to climb one step
named for chocolate bars Snickers
KitKat's Mars oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this is
pretty much the time it takes this cat
to give up name three websites youporn
pornhub Eskimo to the time it takes this
dog to squeeze through the wall name
three American football teams go the
page take hold on Ravens Eagles Jaguars
and the time it takes this dog to
abandon it stick named for things you
found that cargo telephone phone charger
listen that was dumb hey no I wouldn't
got that by the way very smart dogs he
said [ __ ] this dick
he just went on the bothers day at a
time it takes this pug to wake up name
three things beginning with J go alright
Jumanji jokes
Jupiter Oh what did she just get it dog
this smell make your ass and the time it
takes this rat to eat a piece of pop
one name three sports played without a
ball boxing that rats gonna die he's
gonna choke on that popcorn and the time
it takes this cat to make a leap of
faith name three famous Americans go
Tenderheart
the rain a lot Johnson hits it and then
he could because of the cat that's
genius
in the time it takes this iguana to pick
up the worm name three British people go
Queen
Harry blunt all right and the time it
takes his dog to a sin to the ceiling
named for things beginning with T tags
pen [ __ ] I don't know man
I panicked man I felt like the dog was
gonna die I got real nervous
and the time it takes this Rhino to
break his twig name for film starring
Kevin Hart okay go right along so play
Central Intelligence your mother how
does a rhino take that long to break
into it first well go I want to give a
speech cuz it's weird I feel like I'm
always winning and I think you know look
the movies that I've been in have shined
because you helped them and I can only
hope that Jumanji does the same and with
your support - the lack of knowledge
from my co-star
I hope that uh you know we can continue
to grow man I love you guys thank you
[Music]
thank you
you